Priti Patel arriving for a face-to-face
meeting with Harry Dunn's family with
Harry's mum Charlotte - emotionally
tired to be present the Home Secretary
and MP Andrea led sir met with her
husband Bruce and Harry's father Tim the
purpose to discuss the extradition
proceedings that have now begun to bring
and cyclists back to the UK to face
charges in connection with Harry's death
really about how the process has been
difficult - what we can do to try and
improve it after the 90 minutes meeting
a brief statement for me it was a nice
opportunity really to hear from them
obviously about what they've been
experiencing what they've been going
through and to reassure them as well
obviously at what has been a very very
difficult and traumatic time for them
we've had some low points in the last
couple of months where we've you know
thought everybody was against us since
that's how it's been the information was
but now we yeah it's been a great week
and some positive feedback from certain
people has been so supportive it's been
brilliant it's just two days since the
Crown Prosecution Service confirmed that
42 year old mrs. cyclists will be
charged with causing death by dangerous
driving news which delighted Harry's
family the visit by the Home Secretary
here today is further proof that the
government want to be seen to be
treating this case as very much a high
priority Boris Johnson has already said
that they will continue to press the
American authorities at every level on
behalf of Harry's family Perry was
killed when his motorbike was involved
in a collision with mrs. cyclist the
wife of an American intelligence officer
outside an RAF base in August she then
left the country claiming diplomatic
immunity a lawyers say she has
cooperated fully but will not willingly
return to the UK we have a very clear
process in the United Kingdom there is a
clear extradition treaty and it's
absolutely vital that we get justice for
Harry so it will go through the proper
processes
the legal process is now underway
for Harry's family despite the
reassurances from the highest levels of
government that will mean a nervous
weight as they continue to seek justice
for his death
Fraser Maud Sky News Charlton near
Bambury